in this video we'll be talking about
puromycin and how it works at a
molecular level so this is included in
the quick concept playlist where we
discussed topic within 3 to 4
minutes now let's talk about how Pur
puromycin works it's basically a potent
antibiotic and this particular
antibiotic inhibits the translation and
the way it inhibits translation is
allowing the peptide bound puromycin to
detach from the ribosome which lead to a
truncated protein formation so this is a
little bit details how Pur pomy works so
first pomy has a structure which is very
similar to Amino aile TRNA that you can
see
here second this particular structure
can easily incorporate itself into the a
site of the ribosome and it can actually
blend in or make p peptide bond with the
existing peptide chain in the P
site then once this is
incorporated then what happens no new
Amino asile TRNA can transfer its
peptide group that is why this
particular Puro this puromycin linked
peptidal M has to be dislodged from the
ribosome and thereby a truncated version
of the protein is produced full length
protein is never synthesized this is how
the protein synthesis stops in the
bacteria that is why it is it can be
used against broad variety of bacteria
because each of the bacteria in order to
survive need to produce some enzymes and
need to translate proteins right so
let's talk about the uh mode of action
in bit more details so translation has
three broad steps initiation elongation
and termination in a separate video I
have talked about it you can find the
video in I button anyway elongation is
the step which is hindered by this
particular
antibiotic so this is basically the
ribosome here you can
see how the peptidal transfer activity
is taking place and the peptide bond is
forming so basically there is a series
of nucleophilic reaction which lead to a
peptide bond formation between the amino
aile trnas that is sitting in the p and
the a
site so in eventually these peptide
chain Grows by adding more and more
amino acids now what happens is in this
sequence of growing peptide when a
um pomyen molecule enters the a site
then it can also form a peptide bond
with the growing peptide
chain so here you can see the pomy can
also bond with the existing Amino aile
TRNA and thereby forming a m called
peptidal puromycin peptidal puromycin
doeses not hold into the ribosome
properly so it detaches and dislodges
from the ribosome thereby peptide
synthesis is blocked full L peptide
cannot be synthesized bacteria would
eventually die this exactly is the
mechanism how puromycin works now let's
talk about this uh puromycin resistance
is the big concern these days doctors
worldwide are concerned about puromycin
and second of all puromycin is used as a
broadspectrum antibiotic because you can
cleanly understand be it gram positive
bacteria be it gram negative bacteria
everybody need to synthesize protein in
order to survive if that fundamental
aspect is targeted then bacteria would
be dying but again you can understand
these antibiotics would have very potent
uh action against human uh body as
well
mostly puromycin is used in case of
laboratory purposes research because in
order to study translation stop
translation in these kind of aspects
pomy is potentially used so I hope this
video was use useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe thank
you